[Music]
this is one of the most ambitious if not
the most ambitious handmade animated
films ever you can spot a Wes Anderson
movie from a mile away with movies like
The Life Aquatic with Steve Zissou
moonrise kingdom and the grand Budapest
hotel he's shown that every little
detail counts in 2009 he jumped into
stop-motion animation with the instant
classic fantastic mr. Fox now he's
giving it a second go with Isle of Dogs
a film set in a dystopian Japan overrun
by dogs in reality it was shot on
massive handcrafted sets in a studio in
England stop-motion movies require
unique skills to get made every movement
of every character has to be carefully
placed then filmed but Wes Anderson
seems to take it up a notch so how does
he create animated films that mirror his
signature moviemaking style one element
that made Isle of Dogs particularly
challenging fur animators usually place
facial expressions on the puppets that
was easy to do for the film's human
characters in which new faces were
simply placed on top of the silicone
skin it's much tougher when you're
dealing with four legged characters
covered in fur that you can't remove
each puppet has a metal armature inside
which helps it move the dog's faces had
to be moved by an animator meet and ijen
ahead of the movie's puppet Department
who also worked with Anderson on
fantastic mr. Fox or they got plenty of
experience making moving animal puppets
they look good yeah one of the things
was you know said that the fur moves a
little bit it's got to feel like it's
been you know in the wind sort of
touched fur on stop-motion puppets is a
very tricky thing to do and it's
normally avoided at all costs but as
with wares it's like well why is it
avoided let's just try it so making this
happen is going to be a lot easier than
making this happen in Isle of Dogs they
took it to the next level animators use
pins or wooden sticks to move their
eyeballs and lips and give them real
motions and facial expressions previous
most fantasy mr. Fox we had about 370 so
we had eleven hundred and five at the
end of this that's a lot of fur Anderson
pushed the animators to their limits
scenes involving Looney Tunes like
cartoon clouds of smoke were constructed
using wool meanwhile a sushi making
sequence took eight months to bring to
life and the puppets ranged in size
while some puppets were the size of a
fingernail others were big enough to
climb into while stop-motion is an
old-fashioned art form it is not going
anywhere with the invention of video
cysts and digital cameras we can see
things immediately and it means that we
can do way more sophisticated and and I
think one of the things that's really
changed at is that it's become very
accessible to people so most of my
friends kids are doing stop-motion at
home which when I started out like you'd
have to be at university before you even
think about getting to that future it
seems might be full of fantastic mr.
Fox's and robotic dogs
[Music]
[Music]